In modern times.
We look back at the Nazis third or I can wonder how on earth anyone could've
followed out of hello and it was so clearly an evil dictator.
Well,
this was all thanks to yourself.
Girdles the minister of propaganda.
He knew exactly how to manipulate the minds of a nation with fake news,
Nazi idealized the books and propaganda films.
Goebbels was single handedly responsible for brainwashing entire populations and
destroying people who were caught in his web of lies.
Today on biographics,
you're going to learn how one man convinced millions of normal German people to
all become faithful Nazis.
Okay,
cool.
Oh,
yes.
Of gerbils was born on October the 29th 1897 in a small town outside of
Dusseldorf.
His father Fritz worked in a factory and his mother stayed at home to take care
of him and his four other siblings.
His family never had a lot of money,
but they still paid for him to go to a private.
All boys,
rem and Catholic high school girls was born with a disability where the bone
marrow of his feet never developed properly and Z had a club foot.
His parents paid for him to have an operation in order to correct the issue,
but even when both of his feet were pointing in the right direction,
he's still needed to a metal brace on his leg for the rest of his life.
This operation,
it stunted his growth and one leg was permanently shorter than the other causing
him to have a limp.
He also had chronically inflamed lungs and got sick very often.
He grew up to be very angry at the wells and he felt that life was unfair.
He decided to focus a lot of his time and energy into reading books and getting
good grades.
This disability,
it prevented him from doing military service during World War One he was able to
on an academic scholarship and attended the University of Heidelberg.
He stayed in school for years and earned a phd in philosophy in 1921 at this
point,
he completely rejected the teachings of the Catholic Church.
He wrote about his personal ideas of how he thought the world should be and saw
himself as a great philosopher and to think of unfortunately.
Then though,
well,
no one else agreed.
He was very loud and outspoken and was always trying to get noticed.
Even then,
he was very antisemitic and many of his opinions whips so hateful that the
articles and books were rejected for publication.
He decided to create his own publication for his opinions,
but very few people actually cared to read it by all accounts.
He was a failed writer,
runs an incredibly damaged,
there's all man.
He made a bit of money being a tutor and finally sold a few articles,
but other than that,
he had this alter,
no money to speak of.
All of this motivated them to join the Nazi party in 1924 at this time,
Germany was going through a tremendous financial depression and the Nazis
promised that they would fix the country with the Nazis Goebbels.
He finally found a home and a group of people who were actually willing read as
hateful work.
They thought that he was absolutely great at creating pro Nazi propaganda.
Indeed,
it was good enough to convince new members to join the party.
His work indeed helps get out off Hitler elected when he rose to power.
Hitler appointed gobbles as the minister of propaganda since he was unemployed
at the time.
This is very literally changed everything overnight.
Suddenly his life had meaning and see,
truly looked up to adult Hitler as well,
his best friends and indeed his savior.
[inaudible] gave Goebbels the task of censoring any media that may conflict with
Nazi ideals.
He began to give the order of burning books that were written by certain
authors.
Some of the books that gobbles destroyed middle of a sentence like the socialist
philosophy of Karl Marx.
However,
some of the choices of band authors seem to be a bit random and there's no real
logical explanation as to why gobbles would want to raise them from history.
This has led some people to speculate that he wanted to destroy certain authors
just out of petty jealousy,
that they were better writers than he was.
This gave him a taste of authority and a taste of control and he loved it.
Aside from censoring the media,
Gobble set out to create new cons ends in order to replace it.
Kind of always knew that one of the most powerful ways to incite emotions in
human beings was three movies,
the largest film studio in Berlin.
It's called the universe in film,
Axion,
Gazelle shaft or the Ufa for short.
They were well respected throughout the world for producing beautiful silent
films like metropolis.
In 1927 one of Goebbels,
his first orders of business was to forcibly take the studio over on behalf of
the Nazi government.
Both girdles and Hitler were huge movie buffs,
but they made the decision to send the American films from the public.
Adult fell.
There's still had all of the new releases from Hollywood in his personal
collection,
but no one in the general population was ever allowed to see them.
Yes,
of gerbils set out to make sure that everyone working in the German film
industry was loyal to hit blood.
Any of the actors who refuse to shun any Jewish people from their lives and join
the Nazi party were blacklisted from ever working again.
Many of them were even prevented from leaving the country,
and some actors even chose to commit suicide.
Actresses from throughout Europe,
auditions for the prestigious Ufa studio had no idea that they were walking into
a trap.
As many of them signs multiyear contracts before the Nazis came into power.
So while there were some actors who would not see,
as many of them were forced to participate in these films against their will go
all set out to create German versions of some of the big blockbuster hits in
America.
He also created movies where the only goal was to brainwash people into
believing Nazi ideals.
It,
some of them were clearly propaganda,
like one gold Hitler,
youth cracks.
There's other films.
What cleverly disguised subtly changing the opinions of Germans to suit the
needs of the Nazis.
For example,
the 1941 movie I accuse was orchestrated to get the general population to agree
with the Axion t four program,
which pushed for euthanization of disabled and Tom and Leo people.
The plots of I accuse is about a doctor at the peak of his career.
He gets married to a beautiful young woman.
I need to find out that she has been diagnosed with Ms. Mack.
Then the treatment for ms was nothing like it is today and there's no cure for
the disease.
This means that the wife was dying a very slow and painful death.
She begged him to give a lethal injection so she could be put out of our misery.
He struggled with the decision,
but ultimately assisted in how suicide much of the movie takes place in a court
of law where they are trying to decide if this man should be guilty of murder or
if he was doing her a favor by killing her.
Despite being a propaganda film.
It's actually very well written.
Even today.
Anyone who watches the film may find themselves questioning their own morals,
which is why it was considered to be one of the most dangerous propaganda films
ever made.
The movie convinced people that assisted suicide was only going to help their
friends and family members who were suffering.
So the [inaudible] program,
it was passed and listen,
people were then taken from their homes and killed in the name of a perfect
master race.
The same kind of brainwashing.
It happens over and over again in the movies.
And honestly,
if I was,
he didn't just help gerbils.
Korea,
it's also helped him get into a relationship after graduating from is all boys
school.
He was not used to speaking to girls at 34 years old.
In 1931 he married a fellow Nazi named Magda.
Henslow was the best man at their wedding in the public eye.
They appear to have the perfect German marriage.
They had several children together and they lived on a huge gated compound in
the woods outside of Berlin.
However,
use of Goebbels had a reputation for objectifying women and since he was
surrounded by beautiful actresses,
he can beat you.
Took advantage of his position.
According to the testimony of a woman named Anneliese Uhlig,
she was given the starring role in one of the movies that was made at the Ufa
studio.
Girls asked her if she wants it to go for a drive and talk about the movie,
and he drove her straight to his compound.
He offered her a drink and began to force himself on her.
She started kicking and screaming and got free from him.
He said that if she did not meet his demands,
he would make sure that she never had a career in the movies.
She decided to take a chance and ran out of the door bust.
When she showed up the next day to work,
there was an announcement that the film was cancels and Uhlig was blacklisted
from ever working in Germany again.
Yes,
I've gobbles did this to women on a regular basis,
but he did actually fall in love with one woman named leader bar over.
She was one of the few actresses who was truly a faithful Nazi and she even
turned down opportunities to work in Hollywood in favor of moving to Germany.
She moved from Prague to Berlin in 1935 and married an actor named Gustaf
Froelich fro liquid,
divorced his Jewish wife in order to continue his successful acting career
according to lead a bar ever.
She felt pressured into being in a relationship with Yosef girdles because she
had heard of all of the stories about him ruining other actors' careers.
She knew that if she said no,
there was a huge jobs that she and her husband would never work again,
but she must have been a good actress because he became convinced that they run
away together,
gather all stoles his wife Magda about the affair and said that he wanted a
divorce.
Magda went straight down off atlas saying that nearby river was seducing him and
trying to tend them.
Our Jackpot Gobbles,
begged hitless permission to get a divorce.
He also wanted to move to Japan and give up his position of power.
He was willing to give up everything in order to be with Nida,
but it's even as one of the most powerful Nazis in the Third Reich hosts.
If gerbils was still a prisoner to hit less power,
Hitler refused to let go of those,
quit his job because he was far too valuable to the Nazi cause.
The two men got into a screaming match that was witnessed and heard by dozens of
people.
Hitler RegEd him to give his relationship with Magda.
The second chance he insisted that they give themselves another three months of
living together to try and repair the relationship.
If they could not fix their marriage within those three months,
then he could get a divorce.
Hedler Radha lead of our over to leave Germany within 24 hours,
giving her a one way ticket to Prague after this incident.
Yes.
If Goebbels,
who is no longer one of Hitler's favorite men,
his wife also hated him and his lover was gone.
He was no longer invited over to dinner at his place and they barely even spoke
the other higher up Nazis.
They believe the gulls had become weak and that he was getting insane.
They questioned his loyalty and he was no longer seen as the powerful men that
he wants,
wants.
If he wants it to be back in good graces with Hitler,
he would need to do something extreme.
[inaudible]
I am.
Doubles was desperate to regain hitless trust.
So 1939 he incited a mob by publishing a fake story in the newspaper that said,
a German man had been shot by a Jewish man in Paris.
He spoken the streets claiming that the Jews were trying to destroy society.
He lands an angry mob to burn down a synagogue.
That same year he travelled to Poland's with a documentary film crews or show
what life was like inside of a Jewish ghetto.
The people living in the ghetto and sunken faces wore rags and generally dirty
and sick.
We now know that this is because the Nazis forced them into inhumane conditions
in the first place.
However,
gerbils took this as an opportunity to compare them to animals,
saying that they were choosing to live that way.
He said that they were less human and so that they need it to be exterminated.
This film was called the eternal Jew and it premiered in 1940 in this movie.
He tried to say that Jews what all criminals and that if the Nazis,
I haven't lost the war,
then they may take over the world,
forcing the German people to live in squalor.
Humanity would sink into a tunnel darkness.
It would fall into a dal and primitive state where the Jews to win this war.
They are the incarnation of that destructive force that in these terrible years
has guided the enemy war leadership into a fight against all that we see as
noble,
beautiful and worth keeping.
For that reason alone,
the Jews hate us.
They despise our culture and learning,
which they perceive as towering over there nomadic worldview.
They fear our economic and social standards,
which leave no room for that.
Parasitic drives.
This documentary.
It genuinely frightened the German people and they felt the concentration camps
were absolutely justified after visiting Auschwitz in person,
Yosef girdles wrote that the death and torture of these prisoners were so
gruesome that he did not even want to write the details and his private journal
he wrote,
it may be barbaric,
but they truly deserve it.
All of his efforts to insight hate against the Jewish people.
They paid off and dad off hit the,
began to trust Joseph Goebbels.
Once again.
Then mutual hates was enough to repair their friendship,
but it was that the cost of millions of lives at this point had blood began to
trust Joseph Gurbles with more decisions and the government's since he had even
more power than he did before.
Headless stops making so many public appearances and allowed gobbles to speak on
his behalf.
Instead,
he even gave him the authority to declare war.
In 1941 gavels announced over the radio,
the Germany would be going to war with the Soviet Union.
Goggles did exactly what he did when he filmed the tunnel in Poland.
He brought,
he has another documentary.
Film crews are show Soviet prisoners who were living in the mud,
but king Hoff debt.
He claims that this is how Russian people normally lived,
is that the bullshit?
I think policy was controlled by Jews who were trying to take over the world.
He successfully convinced the German public,
but by fighting Russia,
they were fighting for their freedom.
He stood in front of a crowd of thousands of people at a sports stadium in
Berlin saying that there needed to be a total war.
This was met with thunderous applause,
but as you may already know,
Germany's invasion of Russia is what led to that downfall.
The Germans could not handle the harsh winters in the United States and joins
the allied forces.
Italy switched over to the allies as well as that stronghold in world war two it
was suddenly falling like dominoes.
[inaudible].
Now you can probably tell so far in this story that Joseph Goebbels was always a
bit crazy,
but also the invasion of the Soviet Union has mental states became more and more
unraveled.
He encouraged elderly men and young boys to sacrifice their lives for the sake
of Germany and Babyface,
child soldiers where even sent off to war.
He said that every man,
woman,
and child needed to be ready to die for the motherlands.
According to Bill Fred hove and a man who works on Yossef,
Gerbils,
his staff,
they were.
That's amazing.
When a bomb was dropped in the garden of his house,
the glass of all the windows shattered while everyone else on the staff doctor
for cover.
Yes.
If gobbles never even flinched.
He just brushed the broken glass off his notes and continued reading his speech
as if nothing had happened.
He somehow remained completely composed on the outside.
While the panic inside was tearing it apart at the end of the war,
hadn't had told gobbles that he knew that they were going to lose the war.
He was preparing to go to his bunker with plans to commit suicide.
He appointed gobbles as the new chancellor of Germany and he wanted him to stay
behind and run the government.
Once the allies invaded,
gobbles were so devoted that he simply refused to live without Hitler.
He told his wife and all of his children do clean themselves,
put on their Sunday best and goes to the fear as bunker on April the 30th that
committed suicide leaving gobbles as Germany's new chancellor.
It's not a position he would hold for long though the following day,
Goebbels and Magda poisons their six children before ending their own lives as
well.
So I'm not going to ask if you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
Also,
if you're looking at something else to watch,
I've got another channel called today I found out you'll find that link to do on
the screen as well as below this video,
and as always,
thank you for what.